الإمارات العربية المتحدة بالطبع حليف مهم
للولايات المتحدة في هذه المنطقة ، فلماذا
أبطأت إدارة بايدن
بيع 50 طائرة مقاتلة من طراز F-35
بالإضافة إلى معدات عسكرية أخرى
للإماراتيين ، لذا انضممت إلى إدارة بايدن
الإرهابية في 20 يناير
عندما  تولى الرئيس منصبه
وأردنا التأكد من أن أيًا من
الالتزامات التي تم القيام بها من
قبل الإدارة السابقة التي أتيحت لنا
الفرصة لمراجعتها أم أننا أردنا
التأكد من أنها تظل في
مصلحة سياستنا الخارجية أم أننا أخذنا بعضًا منها
لقد أعلنا في وقت سابق من هذا
العام أننا ملتزمون
بالمضي قدمًا ، وأعتقد أن هذا الأسبوع
كنا نتطلع للتأكد من أننا
نجدد التزامنا بهذا الجهد ، ونريد
التأكد من أن شركائنا الإماراتيين
يفهمون أننا
ملتزمون تمامًا حتى عندما نناقش
التزاماتنا قبل
التسليم وبعده ،
وأنت تطلب توضيحات
للتأكيدات المختلفة التي تم تقديمها
للإدارة السابقة  أن تكون
الإدارة الرابحة التي تقصد بها
أنك تعني ما
لا يمكنني الدخول في تفاصيل
مكانتنا الدبلوماسية لمحادثاتنا الدبلوماسية مع
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لكن يمكنني أن
أخبرك أن المحادثات التي أجريناها
مع كل شريك  جزء من
برنامج f-35 الذي يريد أمه
يريد استخدام f-35 الذي يريد شراء
f-35 um نحن نتطلع للتأكد من أن
أمن التكنولوجيا هو جزء
من هذه أه جزء من هذه المفاوضات
جزء من هذه الاتفاقيات لأن
المحصلة النهائية هي أننا نريد حماية
مقاتلنا ، فنحن نريد
حماية الدول التي
تستخدم مقاتلات F-35
لنكن واضحين تمامًا هنا
هل لدى إدارة بايدن
مخاوف من أن الإمارات لديها علاقات جيدة مع
الصين وأنهم  علاقات جيدة ، بما
في ذلك استخدام تقنية huawei
f5 في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، يمكن أن
يضر بأمن ما هو
f-35 المتصل بشبكة عالية ،
نحن قلقون
بشأن استخدام 5g um في أي مكان في العالم من
خلال عدم الثقة  البائعين أم لدينا هذه
المحادثة مع جميع شركائنا
ليس فقط الإمارات العربية المتحدة ولكننا نريد
التأكد من أن مستقبل
الإنترنت آمن لأنه يوفر لنا
ضمانات للشركات
بأن معلوماتهم آمنة
وأن بياناتهم  آمن لأن
خصوصيتهم آمنة ، هل يمكنني فقط دفعك أم
لا ، هل هي f-35s أو huawei ولكن ليس كلاهما
بقدر ما نشعر بالقلق ، فإن f-35 هي
جوهرة تاج
الولايات المتحدة لقواتنا
الجوية وهكذا  نحتاج لأن نكون قادرين على
حماية أمن التكنولوجيا أم أه
لجميع شركائنا
فالجواب نعم بقدر ما
تهتم بالسيدات فهذه
هي الأحاديث التي لدينا
مع الإماراتيين حول أه حول ماذا
نوع من الخيارات التي يمكنهم القيام بها الآن
للتأكد من أنهم يمكن أن يكونوا جزءًا من
برنامج f-35